Right.
Speaking of the universities though,
I have to talk about high schools for a minute because following her event,
I find it interesting actually before the event and post the event,
the most emails I've gotten are all from high school teachers,
couple from elementary,
but mostly high school teachers.
And the tone of these emails is borderline desperate.
They are absolutely losing their minds because they feel that they are being
compelled to indoctrinate a youth into this type of radical Marxist
postmodernist thinking.
And even though they don't agree with it,
they see the flaws in it and many flaws in it.
They don't feel they have a voice.
We just are afraid to speak up the letters from teachers too.
They're unionized,
which is interesting why they feel so terrified,
but they,
they really feel,
they're sort of feeling like this horrible guilt that you're teaching students
what they know.
They shouldn't be teaching them,
but they don't have any choice but to teach it and they think that it's gotten
worse with the wind government.
What's your sense?
Well,
first of all,
you always have a choice,
right?
So,
you know,
and the choice might be to stick your neck out and risk and risk being targeted.
My experience has basically been as if you could withstand that and not
apologize,
um,
and not backtrack,
then you can,
you can weather the storm.
So that's a good thing that people should know.
I think the wind government isn't absolutely reprehensible administration.
It's my fervent with wish that there isn't a single provincial liberal left in
office after the next election.
I think.
I don't think she's a liberal at all.
I think she's far left of where the NDP was,
say back in the 1970s.
Yes.
Working Class Organization,
I think she's apart from financially reckless.
Um,
she's,
she's dangerous in about six different dimensions.
I think the Ontario human rights commission should be strapped.
Scrapped along with all of strapped.
Yeah.
Scrapped along with the social justice tribunals.
There's all sorts of,
I think the legislation that forced the universities to put these quasi judicial
inquisitions in place.
Like the one that raped Lizzy shepherd over the coal should be,
um,
should be rescinded.
Uh,
and I do also agree with your initial proposition,
which is that the l the public school system is actually in worse shape than the
universities and it's getting worse.
It's getting worse than it is extraordinarily rapidly.
If you go online to the Elementary Teachers Federation of Ontario website and
read their plans for curriculum development there basically they basically state
forthrightly,
um,
that they're attempting to indoctrinate.
They don't use that word.
Students from kindergarten to grade eight into the social justice ideology.
That's,
that's the purpose of education as far as they're concerned to rectify the sins
of the past and to bring about equity,
which is of course equity is a,
anybody who talks to you about equity,
you should immediately run away from because they're very dangerous,
ignorant,
historically ignorant and dangerous people.
Yeah,
it's,
it's appalling.
I'm going to make a video for high school kids.
I'm going to tell them one of the things I would recommend to high school kids
is that as soon as the teacher talks to them about diversity,
equity and inclusiveness,
diversity,
inclusiveness and equity.
So that's an acronym that spells die or white privilege that they should
immediately leave the room.